considering that we had this you know
this huge Tea Party movement in 2010
there's been very little talk about
actually cutting spending really other
than Ron Paul who has been a very big
spending cut plans but far as the other
candidates we've heard very little about
it other than Mitt Romney doesn't want a
lunar colony that I'm pretty clear about
hi I'm Nicolas birth reason TV and today
we're talking with James pepper cookus
of the American Enterprise Institute
thank you Jim for talking to us
happening if you cover economics
government fiscal policy things like
that right now what is the biggest
threat to the American economy and any
possible recovery that you're that
you're covering well the thing that
worries me is this economy just is not
growing very fast it hasn't hasn't grown
very fast for really a decade and if you
look in the future it's not it's not
particularly where particularly fast now
some of those are there's some
demographic reasons reasons I have aging
of the workforce you have fewer people
going into the workforce but there just
seems to be a real lack of vitality in
this this economy and all listen all
those account all the problems all the
deficit problems that problems they all
look a lot worse if the economy is not
growing so what are the government
policies you know my big believer and I
suspect you are too the government can't
really you know it can't mastermind the
economy but it can get out of the way or
set certain kind of frameworks that
allow for bigger growth what are the
things the government should be doing
and what hasn't been doing number one
thing the government can do right now is
really create a tax system which is
pro-growth right now we have it's a tax
system which penalizes capital
investment which is very important for
you know creating new innovation new new
products the new companies of the future
so let's see a taxes in a did penalize
capital so much we have this really high
corporate tax rate I'd like to bring
that down dramatically so I mean that's
not the only thing and sometimes I feel
like on my blog I feel like I'm all
running about its let's cut taxes let's
cut taxes I think that I think that's
part of it what is it what's the
spending equation in creating a debt
hang that were hangover that were in
well it's amazing that during during the
Republican nominating process there's
been very considering that we had this
you know this huge Tea Party movement in
2010 there's been very little talk about
actually cutting spending really of the
other than Ron Paul who has made a very
big spending cut plans but far as the
other candidates they're talking about I
say Paul Ryan's plan you know to cut
Medicare spending the future but as far
as like cutting real things right now
we've heard very little about it other
than that other than Mitt Romney doesn't
want a lunar colony that I'm pretty
clear about but everything else there
they don't want to talk about it why
didn't the stimulus weren't and what
does that tell us about the current
state of macroeconomic theory right
where we had some students under Bush he
had some temporary tax cuts Milton
Friedman said that these sorts of
temporary tax cuts tend not to work
because people know they're temporary
and they don't change the lend of saving
the money they won't change their
long-term let you know spending or
investment or savings patterns if they
think the tax cuts going to go away so
the the president's stimulus we had
three parts ahead has had this tax cut
part which was temporary which no one
thought would work and was dribble down
it was dribble on their very be no
because that's what that's what this hot
new craze behavioral economics that they
should do it turns out it really didn't
work and then he also had this is huge
you know infrastructure spending
component which it's interesting that
people they could have gone and asked a
Congressional Budget Office what was
going to happen they would have said
well guess what these things tend not to
work takes very long to get them up and
running so that that almost was
uninspected I think what the
administration maybe didn't expect was
all the regulatory hurdles that these
project would have to go with so took
them that much longer to get them they
get them up and running so now we now
we're here three years three years later
and the economy is only growing under
two percent over the past couple of
years I mean there has just been these
huge convulsions and you know financial
markets globally locally and what not
what how is it made you rethink some of
your assumptions about you know what
constitutes good economic policy or good
fiscal
uh it's it's really made me you no
wonder you know what do I what do I know
what do I don't know there was so much
about that financial crisis wonder stand
the various linkages people didn't
understand the whole sort of shadow
derivatives market the whole shadow
banking market and I didn't realize
there was so much that it didn't know
about and it really made me more i think
more cautious about advocating this
policy or that policy and thinking a lot
more about what are the unintended
consequences let's look at the
unintended consequences first before we
look at the policy and really taking
more of sort of a do no harm approach
public policy we live in an age where
economists are on the bestseller lists
all the time it seems are we killing
becoming more economically literate as a
kind of voting population and if so is
that is that going to be helpful or do
we have a lot of people who know a
little bit and then that's going to gum
up the works well I wish people would
know a lot more i mean III would like to
see more study of economics and personal
finance in high school because even
though even though you know economist
they disagree in a lot they're in there
they're generally are some big things
they tend to agree and they they still
tend to agree on that you know that tray
that trade is a good thing they know
prices prices need to float freely those
kinds of things hopefully if people are
you know more aware of you know what
sound economics is that you know the
just are the general principles they can
hold a public officials you know much
more accountable understand what they're
doing great well i want to thank jim
petha cookus of the american enterprise
institute for talking with reason TV you
can check out his blog writing and and
other articles at american calm AI or
american calm you'll find it eventually
okay Chris well thank you very much
thank you